could you just introduce yourself my
name is Doug Kenney I'd started the
National Lampoon what if you say I was
the man who changed comedy forever but I
couldn't change myself really blow me if
we're running our own magazine we can do
anything we want knock-knock jokes
knock-knock who's that me me hurt me not
doing the magazine that can go an issue
what total failure
we're selling less than half our print
book the Mormons are protesting the
feminist Teta what do we do to the
Catholics Liza Minnelli we are being
sued by Disney maybe it wasn't such a
hot idea to have Minnie Mouse flashing
her tests she has pasties on high ready
girls
three two one Katrin I'm the woman
you're heading on Kenny Chagrin Falls
Ohio we're barely able to put out a
magazine just barely be able to do
something else the first National
Lampoon movie laser orgy girls
Doug Kenny Chagrin Falls Ohio one of the
riders of Animal House we call this
success mostly an excuse to party
[Music]
failure I do care about you Doug
laughs god damn it
we need to see some money I'm sure it's
gonna be just crazy dog we need to
decide is it clear his gherkin his dick
off here yeah cuz you can make it higher
or lower depending on the size of my dog
these actors don't look exactly like the
real people but come on do you think I
look like Will Forte when I was 27
you think Will Forte is 27
let's hear listen sis this is for the
magazine right
[Music]
you
you